we have a guy on earth he's a big
conspiracy guy he thinks has been like
thousands of alien abduction was racing
on that's I would love to ask him we
actually I would like you to ask you
because we are genuinely curious do you
think that there's been alien abductions
are they I have not seen convincing
evidence
he said based on on the reports the
people have given me
did they verify witness testimony I do
you ask much of course though eyewitness
testimony be high in the court of law it
is the lowest form of evidence in the
court of science ah if you go to if you
go to a scientific conference and say
this is true because I saw it I think
they'll just laugh you out of the room
right it's like come back when you have
a reliable and verifiable means of
recording that information what so forth
so oh hey hey boy alright but at this
moment if you were to be asked you would
say you're not saying that alien
abductions couldn't happen or have
happened you have no evidence I'll just
say the evidence that has been put forth
as evidence is not convincing to a
skeptic right and most of that evidence
is either and we'll find out in a minute
either someone with eyewitness testimony
coming forth giving first-hand account
of what they experienced or it is
something in the sky that they didn't
understand and presumed it to be
something in the absence of actual
evidence to support it could have been
aurora borealis it could've been
something it could have been actually
aliens but could it then but I just I
just bring me an alien then up then
we're good
there's been a few than a pressure ball
well you're quite control how you doing
Kevin good to meet you good to meet you
yeah you're quite convinced of the alien
abductions yeah I mean there's just
alright have you been abducted I have
not okay so you're trusting the words of
other people I'm just going by what I've
seen before as far as much from other
people testimonies as far as I could
yeah yeah like three girls in Zimbabwe
who are five years old and they came
running up there uh playing in a field
they came running up to the house mm-hmm
three little I mean they're little girls
five years old so you don't have a point
of reference to a lot right they've
taken these girls apart separated them
said what did you see they
all said the same thing and they all
drew the same thing so when you see
something like that it's kind of hard to
be like ah you know what those girls
just made that up that's not real okay
so now uh we might have a billion people
in the world today who carry with them a
camera and a video and a video camera
and it's called a smartphone so in the
era of the smartphone where everyone can
record unambiguously what is in front of
them we don't have some increase in the
number of reports of abductions or
anything else that number we have
pictures of extremely rare things now
like like buses getting flipped into the
air from tornadoes there was a day when
you would say hey that's interesting let
me go home and get my box camera to
photograph that that so we knew things
happen we never photograph them we have
such capacity to record today and I
don't see any better evidence than ever
has been put forth so so all you we can
say the girls saw something we don't
know what it is that's not enough
evidence to convince a skeptic that they
were actually visited by aliens well
then that's what you're saying is not
necessarily true because there is a lot
of evidence of recorded documented
unexplainable things in the sky
about it just because you can't explain
it doesn't mean it's a visiting alien
from outer space I'm not saying there
isn't unexplained things in the sky that
that happens all the time especially to
people who don't really know and
understand sky phenomenon especially to
them but by and large you can encounter
something that you can't explain happens
all the time how do you back a lie
admitting you can't explain it you have
removed yourself from further
conversation about it you cannot say I
don't know what that is therefore it
must be a visiting alien from outer
space there's a period goes at the end
of the sentence of there's something I
can't explain
floating in the sky in front of me
whatever you're done what an airline
pilot so those guys are the only ones
that give a lot because they understand
how things move when they fly in
propulsion much better than most of the
average person what I'm saying is I'm
talking about human beings here I don't
care what your profession is I don't
care how many Chevron's are on your side
I don't even care if you're a sign
test the point is what we have learned
and psychologists back this up
scientists found it first then
psychology got invented and they study
this to no end
that the human sensory system is one of
the most susceptible of any data taking
configurations to bias to mood to
misinterpretation to all of these and we
say damn how are we going to do science
when the human sensory system is so
susceptible we let's build machines that
can make the measurements that remove
your eyes that don't use your hearing
that don't require you to taste it that
don't require you would even have to
think about it we measure it now I can
show you this measurement okay yeah I
mean by the way it got extra complicated
in the era of Photoshop because not the
Photoshop practically had an alien
button you press in it throws in a UFO
all right so so even if you produce
photographic evidence in this day of
doctored photos you it's a start
if it's better than your eye witness but
it's it's a start I'm saying grab me an
alien and we're good we're good to go
all these people were sure they're alien
to get one and fine and I don't I'm not
gonna stop you I'm not even going to say
I'm not gonna say you shouldn't do it
I'm not saying there aren't aliens out
there I'm not even saying they haven't
visited produce one and you will
convince every single skeptic there ever
was that's all I mean look it was a
movie at one of the dog movies either
dogs or one of the dog movies right
where the whole movie is in the
perspective of dogs right okay there's a
kid who finds a crashed flying saucer
that the Great Dane had flown to earth
him Marley & Me that's not the dogma
okay so now watch okay another kid says
yes no I don't believe you
because here's all I witness so the kid
brings him to the crash flying saucer is
it okay okay so now let's continue it
was great right very simple that science
it was yes yes that is science I mean
you know and over over Christmas if
anybody was online
half the in
that was convinced that Sinbad starred
in a genie movie called Shazam and
everybody had this same Callay was a
collective memory everybody had a memory
was illusion right right and they were
all ingredients that this movie had
happened and and it was a thing until
Sinbad came out and said the reason
there is no record of this movie is
because I was never in a movie called
Shazam I was not in a genie movie I've
never played a genie in a movie but
because people remember it and because
their friend remembers it and because
the other people on the internet
remember it these are cognitive failures
of the human memory and and and the
sensory system is in there as well we've
known this if you count how many people
said they witness Bobby Thomson's home
run or or you name some other Babe Ruth
pointing pointing you if you log how
many people were say they were at the
game if far exceeds the number of seats
in Yankee Stadium and some of those
people actually believed they were at
the game yes they said most of our Liars
though some are whatever like on purpose
others believed they were actually there
I mean there's a high and they can and
if you believe something that is not
true but you're compelled that it is
true you'll pass every lie-detector test
right I mean you're it's what you
believe in cuz you believe it but right
something is being covered up Troy yeah
well wait so now so we haven't gotten
the conspiracy part yet so what all
conspiracy theorists have in common but
everyone I've met and spoken with is
there's a point where the data either
don't agree with what they already want
to be true or there's just an absence of
data and so when they get to that point
they invoke the conspiracy and it's more
often where the data don't agree with
what they want to be true that they'll
say oh it's being covered up or withheld
or purposefully masked so that they make
you think something else instead of the
actual truth so there's always some
gapping going on in the data and the
gapping in every case is the assertion
that there's some powerful secret agency
that is covering it up and I'm I'm
charmed that many people think it's the
US government that that is assigning a
level of competence to the US government
far behind
anyone who's actually worked for the
government will report to you about you
guys true you think the government's up
to some [ __ ] yeah I think that some [ __ ]
yeah yeah what let me don't get me wrong
the government always up to something
he's always trying to keep a secret that
the question is whether they will
succeed in keeping the secret of
stockpiling it look how much we knew
about President Clinton's genitalia it
was ever a state secret it would have
been wait what he does with his you know
we he puts it all right but there it was
on TV how do you respond it at the
competency angle well first of all I
think that you know you said with
conspiracy theorists they they believe
one thing I think non conspiracy
theorists do the exact same thing in the
other direction where they're so far
convinced that they won't ever go oh you
know what that's that's actually uh
that's actually interesting as far as
like Roswell goes the crash in Roswell
the day after it happened the army the
issued a press release saying that there
has been a UFO that crashed in Roswell
we have recovered bodies then all the
sudden the next day it's it's a weather
balloon and it's like how do you how
would you mix those two up so it's it's
it's multiple things like that in you
right there there are no alien bodies we
don't seem but there are things like
somebody the rescue they have alien
bodies probably in Roswell I I mean I
would did you see alien autopsy the oh
that was terrific
no that was fake no it wasn't are you
talking about the the documentary where
they went through and they supposedly
had a fake alien autopsy debunk that
yeah do you think that it's possible
that some of the sign one by the phone
on the wall had a coiled handset which
came up
ten years later than behind it is
amazing how they blew his heart out one
little bit do you think that there is a
possibility that some of the scientists
and their data actually have incorrect
data because of what the government does
yeah but there's just so many things
though that point to the direction that
there would be aliens that it's so hard
to discredit everything I'm gonna tell
you cause they totally discredited I
mean all these people are crazy the
thousand siblings crazy they were all
humans so there were also satellite are
though and so I never sees the word
crazy I never said that all I'm saying
is what you're presenting and what you
think is legitimate evidence simply
isn't scientific okay well and I'm not
using different rules to apply to you
then
I went to any of my colleagues saying
anything else about much less
interesting things in the universe so
what about these people that claim to be
abducted that have had certain things
implanted in their body that are not
found on earth
crazy liars that's that I it's not cases
no no there's nothing in their body that
no one is able to identify yeah that's
that's not true they found stuff they
found implants that remediate meteors
meteorites what we should do if an
immediate idea what I mean
tiny well I'm saying is give me the
aliens until you can do that we have
nothing to talk that where they get that
meteorite oh I'm saying me rights all
over the earth Oh what is found in the
body of meteorite evidence you're saying
they found this what I say it is I have
set the bar for you until that bar is
crossed we actually don't have much to
talk about and I'm not going to stop you
from capturing the aliens go right ahead
do it you know that's kind of my sense
of it is if an alien has the power to
cross the galaxy and show up at earth
it's not going to show up to a farmer in
the backyard that has to then tell us
what the farmer saw or two five-year-old
children that'll be a major thing that
will go unmistakeably down in history as
an alien visitation that is my sense of
it but I bring produced the alien and
we're good then all of you will be
vindicated don't you want that to happen
all of you the crazies yeah oh yeah
don't you want to be vindicated and
lokos they just until that happens don't
expect scientific skeptics to jump on
your bandwagon just don't expect that
and I've told you why tell me about the
thing with the similarities oh would
they say that
they the people that have been doing a
research what a foe I'm always so
scientists are people too right hey
porky remember Bob McAlister all kidding
aside good point thanks I brought that
out of a good addition people doctors
scientists whatever you want to call
them that have documented the alien
abductions people scientist every time
you want to throw on well I'm with your
listen Kelly abductions as report Orcs
our personal eyewitness testimonies of
events that happen to themselves sure
okay just let you be clear
okay but just by I'm distinguishing the
quality of your data all right just
saying these alien abductions that
happen no these are alien junctions that
people say happened okay
just be clear that's we as a scientist
we distinguish the sources of
information otherwise it's this it's
this it's a it's a jumble of he-said
she-said and so so you mean the alien
touches that people say they have
experience yes then the people that have
the doctors that have been documenting
them yes there's there are certain
people that speak with people that claim
to be abducted there are thousands and
thousands of thousands of abductions and
they they have research on what they
have done to them and a lot of them a
lot of the people that have been
abducted have the same blood type
the like 45 49 percent of the people so
but for that to be claimed to be an eye
and eye colors a lot of them most of
them have green eyes oh so maybe they're
specifically looking so green eyes type
whatever so I mean it just is that
enough evidence to say there's aliens no
but that's definitely something that's
like oh that's a little little odd
that's all the way so keep it keep at it
go ahead I won't start I think he knows
I think he knows I'm not authorized to
divert you thank you have you any guests
Troy if if you had to guess if because
he's talking science cuz I mean Neil
deGrasse Tyson is a public figure of
science sure but if you think you were
having drinks with him and just saying
like let's really all the record off the
record we're like people because it
would be major news if he came on this
radio show knew about alien yeah but on
the record authorized to comment belivet
I think you're just talking in the other
grass Tyson he's got the inside scoop he
knows what's going on he does he's he's
he plays it down for the radiograph to
you know where he's going to reveal it
by the way I he's promoting start off
Monday 11 o'clock on that geo yeah I'll
have a public announcement oh yeah